foreign
so much
and maybe
maybe if you open yourself up do it
there's a possibility I don't think so
Quinn
quell
I don't think so well what I'm trying to
say Peter you know this is an open line
right what we're listening to everything
you're saying and it is painful and
you're just telling me now we were
hoping I would stop on its own but I
switched it over to private what color
button did you push blue for the blue
suit oh no blue was the Open Line for
everyone orange is for blue what black
is for orange yellow is for green green
is for red and red is for yellow no
yellow is for yellow green is for red
red is for green I don't think so try it
then
oh
you're right
I'm so sorry about this Yoda oh please
we're here to save the life of our
friend that is all
we paid her to help us get in and get
out you think that'd mean oh I'm gonna
help you do it in a way that no one
knows it's happening but no what she
means is I'm gonna shoot people threaten
people's lives
and I know you're probably asking why
would I trust her well that's a good
question
the answer is
we used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw her off a magic cliff and she died
and then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is
everyone else who died in the past
stayed dead not her why was it the magic
Cliff I don't know that's some freaking
infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass Earth dude who met a
girl fell in love
that girl died and then came back a
total dick
you left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it